all right so this is this is pretty
exciting news we just got a we got a new
right we have a new right a new human
right so take out your notepad or your
your scorecard however you can check of
this and and write this down because
this is a pretty cool one I have to say
this new right that is just I guess Ben
Ben Ben beamed down from the clouds and
been somehow injected into our souls I
know how it works exactly metaphysically
but the new right is the right to live
near your job that's a human right now
to live near your job is is a human
right pretty great I know Beto was
recently better O'Rourke was recently at
an pain stop and he explained how we all
have this right or will have it I guess
in Beddoes administration which will
never exist so let's let's check this
out watch it watch this here's a tough
thing to talk about though we must rich
people are gonna have to allow or be
forced to allow lower-income people to
live near them okay so all right wait
wait one second rich people have to
allow or be forced to allow lower-income
people to live near them what is what
does that mean first of all are they
disallowing it now is that how it works
or a rich neighborhood they put a sign
up saying no no poor people allowed here
III mean the thing it seems to me the
thing that prevents a lower-income firt
person from living in for instance
Beverly Hills is that the houses are
very expensive but if a poor person came
up with thirty five million dollars in
wanted to buy a house there which if
they did they wouldn't be poor anymore
but if they did come up with that money
they could buy the house it's really
that simple so it's not that rich people
are getting up are preventing
prohibiting poor people from living
there it's just that the houses are
expensive because everybody's rich and
so that's the way that works so what are
we going to do to solve this problem
we're gonna convert mansions into into
like low income apartment complexes and
how are we gonna do that are we gonna
force people to move out force a rich
person to sell his house so it can be
converted convert it into a I mean how
does that work well maybe maybe better
will explain it let's keep watching
which is what we fail to do in this
country right now we force lower-income
working Americans to
five one two three hours in either
direction to get to their jobs very
often minimum wage jobs so they're
working two or three of them right now
all right well just what we got to stop
there for just one more second because
who who is driving three hours to a
minimum-wage job okay tell me who's
doing that
who's driving through six hour round
trip for a minimum-wage job so that
would be like I guess if if somebody
lived in Pittsburgh and they drove to
Toledo Ohio for a minimum wage it's like
if you if you lived in Pittsburgh and
you drove to an Arby's to work at an
Arby's in Toledo that's what that would
be but that would make a lot of sense
considering on the way from Pittsburgh
to Toledo
you're gonna pass a lot of Arby's trust
me I've made that drive before a lot of
Arby's and and many other fast-food
minimum-wage jobs there's there's
thousands of them literally thousands of
them in Pittsburgh and then all along
the way to Toledo so it just wouldn't
make any sense to do that
so unless you live in the wilderness and
you're commuting to your job on a via
via covered wagon I don't see how this
could even be possible but this is what
you get on the left a lot of times you
get you get laws and policies proposed
based on these sorts of utterly absurd
scenarios which they're only
undercutting their own case now if you
want to make the case that there are
people go to lower paying jobs and have
to drive an inordinate amount to get
there yeah I mean that's true there are
people who drive there are people there
are probably some people out there
commute three hours to a job there
probably I'm sure there are examples of
that but that's not a minimum-wage job
there are people who commute an hour to
a job that pays them not quite enough to
really justified so that sort of stuff
happens but the problem is number one
when you exaggerate like that you
completely destroy your point and number
two this isn't really if you're going to
transition from pointing out this
problem to proposing some sort of
compelled policy or law by the
government see if that's where the
problem
comes into play because there isn't any
law really that can fix that problem but
Beto is gonna propose it anyway so let's
go back to the clip what if as we
propose to do we invested in housing
that was closer to alright we got to
stop there again because what what what
was that hand gesture exactly play that
clip again no what if as we propose to
do we invested in housing that was
closer to where so he's it's a it's so
what if as we propose to do he's like
it's like a thing and it is what does
this got dance move is it getting ready
to do the Macarena or is he sending hand
signals like secret hand signals to
somebody in the audience I don't
his listen I I'm doing it right now
I I speak I'm my hands are very active
when I speak but I feel like my hand
gestures sort of make sense but his are
just disconnected from what he's saying
and it doesn't make any sense
anyway let's okay let's go back to scope
let's finish this this clip from Beto go
ahead do we invested in housing that was
closer to where you work very often
mixed income housing meaning the very
wealthiest are living next to those who
are not the very wealthiest in this
country to make sure that they can both
afford to go to the same public schools
that we really have that as a place
where in this divided country right now
you can come together without regard to
your income or your race or your
ethnicity or any other difference that
should not matter right now what if we
invest it as we propose to do in
high-speed rail and in transit in all of
our cities to make sure that if you do
not have a car or do not want to use a
car you will not need to have one or you
will not be penalized for not having one
right now so
so having cities that are smarter that
are denser that have people living
closer to where they work and where
their families are to reduce our impact
on climate change and greenhouse gas
emissions but also just to improve the
quality of life you know in in these
built environments that's an
extraordinary opportunity and in our
plan to climate change we make those
investments
so that's Beto O'Rourke's point of view
that's what he's trying to say but what
if
we propose to do we don't elect him in
first place and and he can go back to
attending furry conventions
it's like he's wait I think he's waving
in that's what he's doing he's waving in
an airplane he's a he's where he's
working on the tarmac at a Airport all
right um
that's what I every time I see a beto
rally I expect a I expect a commercial
airliner to just land on top of the
audience because that's what it looks
like he's trying alright anyway so so on
Twitter when he shared that clip he
introduced it he introduced it with the
caption saying living close to work
shouldn't be a luxury for the rich it's
a right for everyone and and that's
really what I wanted to discuss it so I
guess I didn't need to play the clip at
all because I really was just the
caption I wanted to talk about but the
clip was funny so that's why I play so
Beto says it's a right to live to live
near near your job it's it's not it's
not a luxury it's a right and in this
yet again is more evidence that the word
right has essentially no meaning anymore
in our country doesn't mean anything so
we may as well not talk about it not use
the word it just doesn't mean anything
the word right traditionally has meant
has referred to something intrinsic to
our nature as human beings something
that very very crucial here something
that does not need to be provided to us
but which we already have by the nature
of the fact that we are human beings and
which the government simply is not
supposed to take away or infringe upon
or interfere with that's how you know
it's a right so if if we're talking
about something that needs to be given
to you by somebody else then that's not
a right at least not by the classical
conception of this idea of human rights
it certainly is not that's not the kind
of rights that our founding fathers were
talking about
so you but it you could have so there
could be things that are even
necessities yet are not exactly rights
and there could certainly be a lot of
things out there that are that are very
nice to have it would make you very
comfortable and and that we would all
like to have but yet are still not
rights
so rights really have very little to do
they have nothing to do with luxury they
have very little to do even with
necessity it's that's not it's just
about our nature as human beings but
we've moved way beyond that now and now
a right is just anything that you might
happen to want is a right anything that
might make your life a little bit easier
is a right and so now we've extend that
to living closer to your job as a right
which I mean and the problem is when you
start when you start going down this
road where you're calling things rights
that are not actually rights and are in
fact luxuries because that is the
definition of a luxury something that
makes your life something that you don't
need but that would make your life
easier that is by definition a luxury
right but once we go down this road of
making luxuries into rights now we have
because we've erased that line which
made a lot of sense things that are
intrinsic to our humh we're saying well
that's not what a right is anymore it's
now this it's sort of this vague
ambiguous thing and then where do you
stop and how do you even define so
living close to your job well okay how
close
thirty minutes fifteen minutes I live
across the hall from my job because I
work it out is that is that sort of
infringing on my because I still have to
I still have to walk across the hallway
I have to walk I have to get up out of
my bed and I have to walk I have to move
my feet literally probably 15 to 20
times there 15 to 20 movements of each
foot to get me into my my job area which
is what you're looking at right now is
that infringing on my rights cuz I still
have to move to get there I do I do
should there be someone should the
government have someone come into my
house pick me up like do like a fireman
carry and bring me into my into my into
my office and then provide me free
waffles and and pancakes and sausage
bacon and coffee I mean it so so how
does this work but if we're gonna say
that no my my rights are being infringed
upon because I'm close enough to my job
15 feet away from it but what K so what
if you're 45 minutes away
is that still our is our jet is that
infringing on your rights where it where
is the right cutoff is it any
within you have a right to be within 30
minutes of your job either right to be
within 15 minutes and who decided this
and why where is this coming from
it doesn't make any sense whatsoever
which is why as I said the the whole
idea and this is very unfortunate
considering our country was founded on
this conception of Rights and it's
obviously very important to to to the
the whole idea of America but
unfortunately the word just doesn't mean
anything anymore so I think we need to
as much as possible find other ways of
of talking about this of you know if we
are if we are advocating for something I
think we have to find other ways of
advocating for it without falling back
on this idea of being a right it is
possible to make the argument that you
could even say you know it would be it
would be best for society if everybody
had XYZ you could you could say
something like that you could even make
an argument for coming up with a law
that would provide everyone with X Y Z
even if it's not exactly a right now I'm
not saying I would agree I'm not saying
that you know the week we could but at
least then we're having the argument on
a on a on a basis that makes sense so if
you want to for example make the
argument that everybody should have
access to high-speed Internet which is a
thing also now fine then make that
argument but don't say it's a right no
we don't all have a right to it's not a
god-given right if it was a god-given
right then God would have just created
the Internet from the beginning of human
civilization I mean if if access the
Internet is a god-given right if which
if you're saying it's a human right
you're saying it's a god-given right
those are that's the exact same thing
means the same thing
god-given right equals human or human
right equals god-given right so if
that's a god-given right then I guess
what god infringed on everybody's rights
up until the invention of the internet
because he put them into a world that
didn't have it doesn't make any sense
the Internet is not intrinsic to our
human nature but
you could still argue that living in
modern society everybody should have
high-speed Internet so they can
participate in society or whatever I'm
not saying I agree with that argument I
don't but you could argue it and then
you could say from there therefore the
government should provide it fine make
that argument you don't have to say it's
a right not everything has to be a right
and just because it's not a right
doesn't mean it's not important doesn't
mean that you know there's no point in
talking about it it just means it's not
a right is all that's it so we just we
need to find more specific language to
talk about these things more specific
and appropriate language all right okay
hey guys by the way I don't know if you
realize this but when you use the phrase
hey guys like I just did you are
oppressing women so get out get out your
other score card you had your your
Rights scorecard keeping track of all
the rights that you have now get out
your oppression scorecard because this
is yet another thing that oppresses
women there's a video making the rounds
online explaining how the phrase hey
guys or really just the word guys in
general the way it's used now is
oppressive to women so let's let's take
a look at this watch this hey guys
welcome back to now this guys is a
simple term it could mean boys or if
you're modern hip it means people at
first glance guys seems inviting
friendly maybe warm even comedic at
times but it like many male default
terms should not be normalized as an
all-encompassing phrase innocent as it
may seem okay stop stop stop there for a
second do leftist know what the word
normalized means they know what any word
means normalized use it all the time
they're always talking about things
being normalized but like an ego meant
Montoya in The Princess Bride I'm
starting to suspect that they don't that
it doesn't mean what they think it means
because they use it so often to
normalize something is to make something
seem well normal
that's what normalized means but you
can't normalize the phrase hey guys
because it's already normal there's no
normalizing something that's all
normal that's like accusing somebody of
I don't know normalizing napkins because
they use the napkin to wipe their hands
off after eating Iraq ribs it's no you
can't normalize that's already a total
normal thing to do so you can't
normalize what's already normal
normalization is like what the left does
with chill with child drag queens or
drag queens story our that is a perfect
example of actual normalization that is
actually also problematic as leftist
like to say because there you have
something that is very much not normal
that is bizarre and weird and unhealthy
and disturbing that the left is trying
to make normal and part of making it
normal is to take this weird disturbing
crazy thing and to end to try to get
people in society to a point where
they're so desensitized to it that they
don't see it as weird normal and crazy
anymore even though it is
that's what normalization is Katun the
phrase hey guys is just a totally normal
thing there's nothing weird about it
and and so you can't normal alright
another question though that I had
before we get deeper into this video is
is who is this person you know you see
these videos all the time of and it's
all it's always the same thing it's
always someone in there in their
twenties you know very very well sort of
put together person in their 20s
standing there with an all-white
background very sort of carefully
instructing us telling us what we can
and can't do from now on
you see these videos all the time online
but they they never give any explosion
about who they are or why we should
listen to them is the thing as if you're
going to make instructions and tell
people what they can and can't do I
think you have to begin by saying okay
here's why my instructions matter here's
here's Who I am so for example if you're
if you're telling people that if you're
trying to give instructions on what's on
what is healthy to eat and what isn't
healthy that would really help to be
in by saying okay I'm Bob Smith I'm a
I'm a I'm a nutritionist I'm a dietician
you know I'm a cardiovascular surgeon
you know give us who you are what your
station is in life and then and then
maybe and then maybe you'll well you
hope you will have established that you
are an authority but with these videos
it's always just some random person
who's just telling us and we're supposed
to do what just well hey that random
person in the video said we can't do
this anymore guys so don't do it all
right let's go back to the to the video
while we may understand the word means
no real harm with a deeper look you'll
understand that we've been ignoring the
cognitive impact on women as well as
gender non-conforming folks by only
explicitly addressing the male
identifying individuals present the
meaning of guys has changed over time
according to the Washington Post
etymologists believe it began in the
17th century with a guy named guy Foxx a
participant in the failed 1605 Gunpowder
Plot he only barely escaped a brutal
execution by jumping off a scaffold and
breaking his neck for the next few
centuries those who likened him in
fashion appearance or intellect were
referred to as guys eventually according
to the Boston Globe the term brought in
to describe creepy people then to a
generic term for men and now some would
say a gender-neutral phrase for decades
we have set a standard of only
addressing the men in the room of course
we claim it's colloquial but with our
elevated knowledge and inclusive
perspective it just seems lazy
inconsiderate and a small part of what
reinforces the gender hierarchy today
how is one to feel empowered to speak or
assert themselves when upon greeting
their misgendered or even ignored in
language can we be surprised that for
decades women often felt uncomfortable
asserting their voice when we didn't
even take the time to properly
acknowledge them okay all right I can't
take it anymore
I mean bro
just chill okay take it easy dude back
off chief I did notice one part though
as she was giving us that etymology of
the word guys very interesting I don't
know if it's true or not probably isn't
but she said that it used to mean creepy
people according to her and then it came
to refer to men so is it isn't the word
guys then offensive to men shouldn't
shouldn't we be the ones offended by it
you're telling us that it used to mean
creepy and then that became synonymous
with men in general put that aside
though I want you to take note of
something else before she starts giving
all these reasons why the term heyguys
is terribly offensive she said something
important I want you to listen to this
part again listen to this while we may
understand the word means no real harm
alright did you get that played again
while we may understand the word means
no real harm again while we may
understand the word means no real harm
again while we may understand the word
means no real harm okay while we
understand the word means no real harm
or make sure we all got that so you
understand that the word means no real
harm well then why are we talking about
it in that case what's the point of the
conversation if you understand that
someone doesn't mean any harm in what
they're saying you have no right to be
offended by it if you know that someone
does not intend offense in what they're
saying if you know it and you're
acknowledging that you know they don't
mean it offensively then if yet you take
offense anyway it's because you want to
be offended and you want to be offended
because you are a petty emotionally
manipulative narcissist trying to make
everything about yourself it's because
you're the kind of person who ejects
yourself into a normal conversation
between normal people who are being
perfectly polite to one another and you
just have to control things because
you're a control freak
okay that's that's what that means and
your feelings in that case mean nothing
mean absolutely should not care your
feelings mean nothing to anyone and they
shouldn't mean anything to anyone
mainly because they're not even really
your feelings you admit that yeah I know
you didn't mean anything by it you're
just trying to emotionally blackmail and
bully us because you want to control us
that's all that is
I've hammered this point a million times
because you you hear this all the time
now in society where people acknowledge
like yeah yeah look I know you didn't
mean anything by that
but I'm offended anyway how is that even
possible how is it even possible to make
yourself offended by something when you
know that it wasn't even meant
offensively the only time it could be
reasonable to take offence at someone's
words is if you reasonably suspect that
they meant to offend you and even then
taking offence is a really sort of a
pretty pointless exercise to take
offense but but at least that it's a
it's a it's a natural response so if
somebody goes up to you and says hey
you're fat you're ugly you're disgusting
well clearly they mean that there's no
non offensive meaning there that is an
insult they're trying to insult you so
if you are therefore insulted that is a
reasonable reaction it may not be a very
fruitful reaction it probably was better
just to ignore it but it is a reasonable
response someone insults you and so you
feel insulted okay fine
and in that scenario the person who
insulted you
owes you an apology as civilized human
beings if you insult somebody once you
calm down and realize that that that was
rude you should apologize but if you
didn't mean anything
and in else okay so this is the way
human communication works right where I
say something and in saying whatever I'm
saying I I mean to convey a message okay
only I can really decide what the
message is I I get to decide the intent
behind what I'm saying and them and the
message it's meant to
convey only myself as the speaker can
determine the intent because I'm the one
saying you cannot retroactively Li
infuse in an intent into what I said
that that wasn't actually present when I
originally said it the very basic
concept so you get to decide which means
now sometimes in human in human
communication somebody can say something
and it's sort of ambiguous it could go
one way or another it could be it could
be read offensively or couldn't be read
in offensively so that in that case you
as the as the listener as the hearer as
the receiver of the words if you're not
sure if it was meant offensively rather
than just assuming that offense was
intended the reasonable thing to do is
to say what did you mean by that
to give the person a chance to clarify
and if they say oh no no I didn't mean
that in an offensive way here's how I
meant it then all you can do as it as an
adult is just say okay understood now if
if I say something that is clearly meant
to be offensive and then I claim later
that I didn't mean it that way well then
then then that's on me and that's called
being passive aggressive passive
aggressiveness exists there are passive
aggressive people out there a passive
aggressiveness to me is one of the the
most unappealing and repulsive
characteristic in a person I absolutely
hate it but there are passive aggressive
people and this is what they do they say
things that they know we're gonna be
taken a certain way and they wanted to
be taken that way but they also say it
in a certain way that it always allows
them and out to claim that they didn't
really mean it that way and that's just
passive aggressiveness so if that's the
case and that's different but as long as
I'm not being passive aggressive then
you just have to leave it to me to
decide what I meant and to tell you what
I meant and again if if if it's clear or
if I tell you no I didn't mean that in
offensive way here's how I mean just all
the only thing you can do is just accept
that
and move on with your life all right one
other one other thing before we get to
emails
pierce brosnan the you know obviously
hollywood actor and and he was a he used
he's one of the the men that's played
James Bond he was asked by Hollywood
Reporter whether there should be a
female James Bond and this is what he
said he said yes yes exclamation point
I think we've watched the guys do it for
the last 40 years get out of the way
guys and put a woman up there I think
would be exhilarating it would be
exciting now and this is getting a lot
of attention and the feminists are say
look one of the James Bond guys this is
you know I did I didn't watch the
interview aside I can't see his body
language of fate but but this to me
reads like a hostage with a gun to his
head
psyche oh yes I would love for there to
be yeah it's about time guys get out of
there the point is and this is what
makes all this so pointless that Pierce
Brosnan is giving the only answer he's
allowed to give so when a media person
comes in and says what do you think as a
Hollywood actor himself a guy that
played James Bond and and he's asked
should there be a female James but the
only answer he's allowed to go because
he knows now I would love it if he had
said no I don't really think of yeah you
know what this is a guy character women
can find their own character I would
love it if he responded that way but
he's not gonna do that
because he doesn't he's a just it's not
worth the trouble for him and can you
imagine if he was asked that question he
had said something like now this is a
guy if a former James Bond had come out
and said no no women are allowed to do
this he would be just the the the the
mob would descend upon him and he knows
that so he has to say oh yeah it's great
and speaking of being sort of
disingenuous and passive-aggressive this
is another thing that you get from the
left and from the media where they ask
questions to people knowing that there's
only one answer they can
give and then when they give it they
report it as if it was a freely offered
in opinion when it when it wasn't there
was a metaphorical gun to their head now
the reality is with this James Bond
thing in general I don't care that much
because it's a fictional character but
to the extent that I do care which is
very little no I absolutely don't think
that a woman should play James Bond that
obviously is silly and and and and
stupid now if you want to switch the
race up and have a black guy playing
James Bond who cares fine
in fact I think I drew cell but and this
is the if I just elbow would be a great
James Bond I think and but it's got
nothing to do with his race nothing at
all to do with this race I think he
would make a great James Bond so the
race doesn't matter here's what matters
with James when it comes to demographics
here's what matters James Bond is
British gotta be British it wouldn't
make any sense to have a James Bond from
Kentucky if you want to have a spy from
Kentucky that's that's a that's a
different character and go ahead and do
that but James Bond is British and he's
a man his maleness his masculinity for
better and worse with all of James
Bond's positive and negative
characteristics as a character it is all
very much tied to the fact that he is a
man it is part of the character in a
similar way that Lera Croft Tomb Raider
not nearly as a iconic of a character
but it wouldn't make any sense to have a
Larry Croft okay although Larry Croft is
already I guess sort of the female
version of Indiana Jones I guess but so
maybe that's not the best example but
but it whatever the point is this is a
this is a man his his his masculinity is
central to the character if you make him
into a woman you it's it's it's a
different character and if you want to
have a female spy then here's here's my
thing feminists go out there and make
female spy character there are already
some in existence go make another one if
you want but stand on your own two feet
okay don't don't try to leech off of a
don't attach yourself like a barnacle to
it to a pre-existing character to try to
borrow the mystique and and the the you
know charm of this already existing
character and the brand and everything
so that you can then parlay it into your
feminist thing go out there and stand on
your own two feet and make your own
character completely separate your own
interesting separate female character go
do that you don't have to that was the
whole thing with the Ghostbusters you
know and the the outrage and the
backlash against Ghostbusters was
completely exaggerated for the most part
people didn't watch it because wasn't
very good but the point is don't these
these Ghostbuster characters they are
they are those characters exist if you
want to make something similar where
you've got a ragtag group of women out
there fighting ghosts and goblins then
go ahead and do that
but don't attach your so don't try to
borrow from the charm and the wit and
the brand recognition of a of these male
characters go out and do your own thing
stop appropriating for all this talk
about appropriate that this is
appropriation it's a very definition of
appropriation to make a Jane bond would
be appropriating James Bond by
definition all right we'll go to emails
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com this is from meg says
Matt I've respected you so much for
years and I've greatly enjoyed listening
to your podcast every day I was also on
your side with the socks and sandals
issue as using precious time and energy
using hands to push regular shoes on is
a such a tragic waste however I just now
saw that the the sandals you wore were
not sandals they were flip-flops every
self-respecting human knows that
flip-flops are for the fair sex only
flip-flops on a man are metrosexual at
best and downright fruity and worst I'm
so relieved that you didn't have a full
body shot because flip-flops on a man
usually are paired with mid thigh pastel
shorts a collared polo tank tops and a
coral pink baseball cap well I've got
news for you Meg I guess it's a good
thing you didn't do the whole outfit
because you nailed it this well aside
from the big the pink baseball cap I do
have some self-respect I would never
wear a pink baseball cap the Sox were
the only redeeming part of the outfit
because God forbid you may have had
toenail polish on under those and so
what if I did you big it what do I did
have toenail polish on if I if I did
this show one day with lipstick on you
would have to just watch it and make no
comment at all if you laughed or smirk
or said that's weird you are a bigot
every grown man can understand that
manly sandals must at least have either
a heel strap or a piece that goes
horizontally across the top Crocs
even are acceptable sheesh man who wants
to see that much of a man's hairy foot
as a woman I can assure you that is
unbecoming of a man to don them I
suggest you donate your flippy floppies
to a large footed woman in need and find
yourself a shoe that doesn't question
your manhood the truth is hard to hear
but must be said first of all my big
hairy man feet are beautiful okay and
I'm not going to hide my light under a
bushel or my feet in shoes just to make
you feel comfortable in your bigotry and
your prejudice and you say that I got so
many emails trying to draw this
distinction between sandals and
flip-flops a flip-flop is just a form of
sandal it is a species of sandal and you
say that men make I hope that your I
hope you're not a Christian because what
kind of footwear do you think Jesus wore
you think Jesus was walking around in in
work boots you think he had Nikes on
know he had flip-flops yes flip-flops
and I have you seen the movies go watch
the movie every single movie you see
Jesus has the flip
pop song would you would you would you
say all this to Jesus Christ I don't
think you would I think I could just
rest my case right there as a matter of
fact I mean gogo watch any biblical
Moses has flip-flops on so what else do
I need to say I am NOT going to be
intimidated and I hope that I I think
that men have been shamed for too long I
think that every man deep inside yearns
to wear flip-flops and socks and the
only reason he doesn't is because he has
been bullied and beaten down by our
society and so I so I hope this becomes
a movement where men can be loud and
proud and say this is how I dress this
is who I am and I'm not afraid anymore
this is from well I didn't get the name
okay Matt I completely agree with you on
paying college athletes when there's a
market for their labor it absolutely is
a free-market position that you've taken
in that matter I wanted to point out
that there are other academic programs
that are competitive that do pay the
student at the students chosen for those
roles PhD programs oftentimes pay
students a stipend because the
university will profit off of the
research the student will be carrying
out these programs are highly
competitive with a limited number of
spots for qualified students it sounds
very similar to the limited number of
highly competitive openings on a
football team the main difference is
that PhD applicants often have other
opportunities in their discipline that
would pay them as well regardless of
that point I see no other reason see no
reason why college athletes shouldn't be
compensated for their labor and the risk
they take out on the field I do
understand that people might not want to
see 20 year olds make millions on a
college football team flaunting their
money and getting into trouble that kind
of money could definitely had negative
impacts on the lives of young person
perhaps the middle ground will be that
they receive the payment in a lump sum
after graduation in addition to the free
tuition they've received yeah I think
that would be I think that would be the
good middle guy I think there are a lot
of different ways of doing it and I also
keep in mind that you know many people
that have emailed me on the subject have
said something like well these guys are
going to go pro and they're
they're gonna get their Millions then so
they don't need to get their Millions
now first of all the vast majority of
people who play in college even at the
d1 level are not gonna go pro even even
there there are many star college
athletes in football I'm talking
specifically about football here because
that's that's what I know better than
the other sports there there are many
examples of these star players who don't
even get drafted or do get drafted and
flunk out pretty quick look at Tim Tebow
and and and he's done well for himself
in other areas so he's not hurting for
cash by any means but Tim Tebow one of
the greatest college football athletes
of all time and he couldn't really hack
it in the NFL so the fact is most of
these guys are not gonna end up with
football teams and even even the ones
who do most of them are gonna are gonna
be gone in three or four years the
average career of manifold players like
three years and most of them don't
survive past that because they wash out
they can't compete anymore they get
injured a lot of different reasons so
the fact is these guys are sacrificing
their body they're putting their life
they're putting not maybe not lie well
in a way their lives are putting their
health at risk at a very minimum and and
most of them will never financially
profit off of it or if they do only in a
very limited and temporary way and which
is yet another reason to pay them okay
from Amanda says greetings supreme lord
over the over overlord of the university
or show is always a highlight of my day
a while ago you mentioned that you
weren't 100% sure about your stance on
recreational marijuana use it's a topic
that it's personal meaning for me as my
husband is a frequent user to
self-medicate his multiple issues from
ADHD to PTSD for some reason weed makes
me less nervous than hardcore
pharmaceuticals plus I like him a lot
better when he smokes interestingly he's
rather he's rarely high but more just
mellowed out and happier when he's using
anyway your opinions are always amusing
and usually correct even if you're going
to written him or me apart over it I'd
be honored to hear it no I'm not gonna
rip either one of you apart I think look
certainly if if anyone who believes that
it's okay to give pharmaceutical drugs
for emotional and psychological reasons
such as PTSD or ADHD or whatever anyone
who's in favor of that for them to
recoil at the idea of marijuana being
used in a similar way is absurd because
those as you pointed those
pharmaceutical drugs are more serious
more dangerous more addictive abused
more often way more likely to kill you
than than marijuana is so certainly but
what you're talking about here is is is
not really recreational use you're
talking here about something that is
well you said self medicate so this is
something like essentially medicinal
marijuana and I've said that I have no
problem with medicinal marijuana at all
how could you I've never heard and I
really mean this I have never heard an
even coherent argument against medicinal
marijuana use
unless it's an argument that is also an
argument against pretty much every other
drug that you find if you go to Rite Aid
or CVS and I guess there are some
extreme positions that say well you
should take any medicine at all of any
kind that's not my position I think
that's crazy too but at least that's
consistent but to say it's it to peruse
the you know the the all of these drugs
at your average drugstore and say oh
that's fine sure but if you smoke
marijuana now that's a problem and wag
your fingers that doesn't make any sense
recreational use I certainly think I am
in favor of decriminalizing it because I
think it's it's simply a waste of law
enforcement resources to be hunted
hunting this stuff down I can remember
living in Kentucky and in Eastern
Kentucky it's a very poor area very poor
one of the poorest in the country but
it's also an area where a lot of people
grow up marijuana plants and every year
they would do these massive raids where
they would confiscate confiscated
millions of dollars worth of marijuana
in these in these impoverished areas and
and it's just why what what have we
accomplished for society by doing that
what's the what exactly is the problem
what exactly is the downside really to
letting these people just grow the plant
make them make their money who cares so
in in when it comes to recreational use
you know it's it's not something that I
want to do but I do find it difficult I
think people who advocate for or use
marijuana will often draw the comparison
between marijuana and alcohol and
they'll say well if you're okay with
with recreational alcohol use how could
you possibly have a problem with
marijuana use considering alcohol kills
more people it has more of an
intoxicating effect it's more tied to
violence etc and so forth and I think
that's a powerful argument and so I I
just I feel like I can't but considering
I do enjoy alcohol I'm a fan of bourbon
I like to sit down of a glass of bourbon
I like to drink beer you know all the
other with in moderation
not to the point of intoxication but I
do enjoy that but so I feel like I just
I can't figure out a coherent non
hypocritical argument that would allow
me to continue drinking when I want to
drink yet would disallow someone from
smoking marijuana it so that's my
position
all right um this is from Roxy says dear
Matt first of all how is your ankle how
was your wife's pregnancy going and how
are your bees also can you please give
me some book recommendations what are
your top five favorite nonfiction books
and your top 5 favorite fiction books I
love your show and listen your podcast
every day the bees are doing very well
my wife is getting ready to give birth
any any any week now my ankle is
recovering okay as I so bravely overcame
that dramatic injury as far as a book or
am I always loved giving a book
recommendation sigh well you ask much
for my favorite nonfiction and fiction
books I'm not gonna give you my favorite
because that kind of changes by the week
and it's also a lot of pressure to give
you my favorites I won't give you what I
do what I'll do is
I'll tell you that the five most recent
books that I've read which I have right
here prepared for this question and so
I'll just tell you that and you can take
those as recommendations so those books
first of all high percentage fishing
which is a statistical approach to
improving catch rates I'm working on
this right now I don't know if you're
that one this is a little bit niche so
you might not be interested in that but
that is I haven't enjoyed this book I
think I mentioned this one Bill Bryson a
short history of nearly everything I
this I this is one of my favorite
non-fiction books I percent recommend it
if you're looking to read nonfiction
pick up this book he calls it a short
history of nearly everything which it
basically is he starts at the beginning
of the universe and in this book is only
what is it that's you know four hundred
some pages but he goes through from the
beginning of the universe all the way to
present day covering all these different
scientific topics it's very accessible
he's a he's a great writer and so
definitely read that I'm working on this
the rise and fall of ancient Egypt I I
am on a thing now where I'm reading
about ancient civilizations this one
it's a it's a good book but it's kind of
a slog brief interviews with hideous men
David Foster Wallace I read this few
weeks ago and this is more fiction is a
collection of short stories
Dave Wallace is someone that you either
love or hate and I think as a writer I
tend to love him I think it's a great
writer very insightful I don't agree
with all of his insights but if you're
looking for shorter fiction I would read
that and then I I read this because
someone recommended it to me we have
been talking on this show about a few
weeks ago we told we were talking about
the the nature of consciousness for some
reason I think we were talking about
that one when someone emailed and
recommend that I read Julian Jaynes the
origin of consciousness in the breakdown
of the bicameral mind and so I did I did
read it I this is a weird book because I
don't agree with almost any of it I I
disagree with ninety-eight percent of
this book but I kind of loved it because
it was really fascinating and I read it
almost more as a sort of science fiction
than anything else but and this is a
well known book I'd heard of it before
first time I tried to read it
what Julianne Jaynes is arguing but he
what he essentially argues is that that
consciousness arose in the human
population very recently he thinks it
arose 3,000 years ago so before about
1000 BC human beings were not conscious
that's what he says and he says that
before that mind at that point what he
calls the bicameral mind everyone was
basically a schizophrenic where they had
their their their unconscious mind that
went through the day-to-day it was kind
of instinctive and it got them through
the operations of day-to-day living and
then what we consider to be
consciousness reasoning moral reasoning
all of that it was like another voice in
their head the other part of their brain
talking to them audibly much like a
schizophrenic today and what he
theorizes is that all of that those
people in fact we're schizophrenic
schizophrenia today is a mental illness
back then it was it was everybody
everybody was was that so it wasn't a
mental illness but they took those
voices which was really the voices in
their head of their consciousness
speaking to them they took those voices
to be the voices of the gods and so
that's where he finds the origins of
religion and so he thinks that all of us
as religious people we have our origins
in schizophrenia so again I don't agree
with it but it's I found an interesting
anyway even though it's completely
insulting to me as a religious person I
still found that to be a fascinating
theory I I have a lot of respect for
people who as I've said before if you
think wildly outside the box and
approach a topic from a completely
different direction even if you're way
off base and totally wrong I respect the
attempt and I at least find it
interesting and I am just so bored with
the same old stuff all the time from
everybody most of
of our conversations in this country
about the issues it's just you have one
side saying one thing the other side
says the other thing nobody's attempting
to say anything unique or interesting or
creative I get so bored with it that
when someone recommends to me some book
that extrapolates on a crazy weird
theory I'm gonna read it because I'm
starving for something different even if
I disagree with it all right so we will
those are my pseudo book recommendations
thank you for giving me the chance to
babble about that for a few minutes
thanks everybody for watching and
listening I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
[Music]